he is the co-owner and CEO and president
of the New York Football Giants John
Mara here on the Rich Eisen show how are
you John I'm doing great yeah I am doing
fine I literally you were one of the
first people I thought of when I heard
all these names today because you you
can put it all together in a way what
does it mean for George Young to go into
the Pro Football Hall of Fame John you
know it for us it was something that was
long overdue you know what he meant to
our franchise when he took over 1979 was
something that is hard to put into words
because we were at the very bottom of
the league at that point in time and and
he lifted us to a place that you know we
suggest dream about building super bowl
teams putting together a great staff and
I really said it is up for success for
many years after that the big thing he
did for us was you know he just made us
more professional in everything that we
did from our medical department to our
equipment department our scouting to our
pro personnel people just everything
that he touched he improved and you know
he set us up for success for many many
years I just wish that he were around to
enjoy this because although he would
have feigned indifference about it I
know it's knowing him I know it's
something that would have meant a great
deal I'm sure it was he pounding the
table for Parcells best you can remember
from back in the day was he an advocate
for for Bill he was he was although
there was you know quite a bit of luck
involved there to it you know at the
time if you were called Ray Perkins who
was our head coach he left us to go to
Alabama and George thought that we had
something good going at the time you
know we had Lawrence Taylor and Phil
Simms and people like that on our roster
and you know George wanted to maintain
some sense of continuity so billet had
some head coaching experience in college
so you know he was the only one on the
staff as I recall that had any head
coaching experience so that so George
went with his garden and Bill ended up
in our head coach and
you know the rest as they say is history
so is there any good story about
Lawrence Taylor and George Jung you know
George was sold on heaven in 1979 I
remember thinking at the time God we
need a running back so badly and there's
George Rogers out there and you know I
had not seen Lawrence Taylor play
because there were a lot of North
Carolina games on TV back back then and
I remember George saying where do you
see this guy he is something special and
you're gonna you know you're gonna be
thrilled that we got him and sure enough
for me from the first practice at
training camp and Pace University you
could see the talent and the fire with
which he played and you know that really
saw our franchise up having him on our
roster and you know and he listened he
made a big pickin 7920 everybody want us
to take a quarterback everybody wanted
us to take Jack Thompson the throw and
Samoan it was a big star back then and
and instead we took you know a little
lone quarterback right now miss Olsen's
out of Morehead State and you know God
really criticized for it kind of
reminded me of our ticket Daniel Jones
last year was it was booed when when it
was announced by Pete Rozelle and in a
sense became a great player for us and
two years later you know he added
Lawrence so but Lawrence was was
obviously probably the best player in
the history this franchise but he was
certainly not without his some
challenges as well and some we lived
through but you know was a great player
always played hard and really set the
tone for the rest of the team
John Mayer a Giants owner CEO president
right here on the Rich Eisen show Paul
Tagliabue finally got the call John I'm
sure you've been in many a meeting with
this man and been many miles of football
miles with him what what what makes
taglio in your mind Hall of Fame worthy
John Rich I can't believe it took this
long for him to get in there I just
don't mean you know he led the league
through some pretty difficult I was able
to
maintain labor peace you know we went
into a whole new era in Endon TV with
our TV broadcast and everything he
oversaw a lot of rules changes that that
made the game better I mean he to me
made so many contributions to the Latian
should have been in trying a long time
ago I'm just happy that he's finally
going going in right now but he was a
great leader for this new you somebody
that all the owners respected I believe
he had the players respect so I think he
was unfairly criticized for certain
things you know but I think it's about
time he got in there and again he was he
was at the forefront of so many of the
innovations that the league has seen
over the last during his his period of
time as commissioner and really really
did an outstanding job there I'm just
happy to finally see him just get into
ten well the two aspects of his
Commissioner ship that stand out for for
me outside obviously the creation of NFL
Network was him saying that
post-katrina the Saints are staying in
New Orleans and then also 9/11 John
obviously we all as New Yorkers live
through that I wonder what his what his
Commissioner ship and guidance at that
time meant for you with you and with the
the organization that was huge remember
sitting in my father's office during
that period and you know trying made a
decision I was going to play played
games in next weekend and and my father
was adamantly opposed to that we still
didn't know how many people have been
killed you know in the World Trade
Center and and Paul was instrumental in
convincing there because there was a
number of owners who wanted to play you
want to go ahead and play and Paul was
instrumental and making a determination
that you know it's not appropriate for
us to play and instead we got to be
thinking about all the families who've
lost loved ones and we got to treat the
next weekend you know solemnly and not
be playing football
and he was using the other thing you
didn't mention he was very much behind
the NFL returning to Cleveland as well
so I think between Cleveland and and and
you know staying the course in New
Orleans what he did in I 11 start in the
NFL Network and you know a million other
things he is certainly deserving not all
Fame inducted John Mara here on the Rich
Eisen show I'm personally I couldn't be
more throwing and emotional when I talk
about Steve Sabol he's one of my
favorite people I had the I've had the
pleasure of getting to call colleague
and a friend and to meet throughout
night now 17 years coming up on NFL
Network what's your favorite memory of
Steve John there's all the incredible
content that he has created over the
years and he would come into owners
meetings and and talk about you know
some new innovations that they were
going in some new programming that they
had mine and everybody was a fan of
these I mean what he meant to the league
in NFL silica this is a unique
organization and I think I set the
standard for many many years for sports
programming and and the creativity that
Steve had and employed great programs
that he's put on over the years I think
are just so unique and have meant so
much to the league and and to all of the
teams that he's a very deserving
inductee and again you know it's kind of
a sad thing you just wish you don't play
around to enjoy his family because I
think himself in it would have meant a
great deal to him well I'm sure he and
his dad and facendo all getting together
tonight I mean we all grew up with it
you know the Johnson senda you know
doing the you know the audio for all
those great the highlight shows and
everything else and Steve and his dad
are such a big part of NFL history it's
it's great to see him going into the
Hall John Mayer president CEO co-owner
with Steve Tisch at the New York Giants
here on the Rich Eisen show I'd be
remiss if I didn't ask you a couple of
more contemporary questions John you
said that your new coach Joe judge you
got the right guy
and that
blew you away in the conversation you
blew all of us away by naming him not a
lot of people saw him on a radar screen
John what you see well you know rich his
interview and and it's been pointed out
by more than a few people in the local
media that I've had a lot of experience
interviewing head coach and candidates
in recent years but this was the best
interview I had ever been a part of he
just was so prepared and so poised and
so confident it displayed such great
knowledge about what it takes to build a
winning football program and drawing on
the experiences that he had at Alabama
and then with the Patriots and
everything he learned from from Saban
and from from Bill Belichick I just
he just was the whole package and you
know the way he handled the introductory
press conference was very impressive -
you'd think he'd been doing that for 20
25 years and he had never done it before
so you know he's young he's only 38
years old but he's got a certain energy
about him and a certain Drive and I
always remembered gorge on talking about
what do you look for in a head coaching
candidate his big it's big qualities
were you know intelligence do they have
something to prove and energy level
those are all huge things for him and I
see all those factors in Joe now you
know we'll see we haven't played a game
yet but you know we like what we've seen
so far and he's in the process of
putting the staff together right now and
let's say so we have nowhere to go but
up I love that that's a total New York
or New Jersey statement right there man
that's in terms of putting the staff
together word is you've got a former
head coach in the division who has
experience that could add to the staff
and Jason Garrett in the building as we
are talking is that a is that a fact
John he is in fact in the building yeah
I think he's talking with y'all right
now and you know this will be Joe's put
his staff together and you know we'll
see if it works out with which
and I know he's been very deliberate
he's talking to a lot of people bring a
lot of people in here and I think that's
the right way to go about it there's no
you know any prize for being the first
one to assemble the staff it's more
important to pick the right guys and you
know we'll see what happens with Jason
obviously I'm a big fan of his having
you know Jason having played here and
you know let's face it we had a tough
time beating him free for a lot of years
that he always seemed to meet us down
there so I think he's a good football
coach and we'll see if it works out why
and what do you like about him so much
that's an open-ended question I've met
him
yeah he's a quality of such a quality
person yes you know integrity in class
he's very smart guy he loves football
I'd love to talk about football I mean
there's a million things to like about
Jason but most of all he's just a real
quality individual last one for you John
Mara you are on the NFL competition
committee and you are a an important
voice in that room how do you think the
year of pass interference being
reviewable has gone well obviously a lot
of us including myself are very
uncomfortable with where it sits right
now but and I said this before you know
we will sit down at the end of the year
and review probably every pass
interference call it was made this year
and probably a number of whom were other
calls were not made and we'll talk about
it I want to get a chance to see all of
them before I pass judgment on it sounds
like gonna be a fun couple of days
doesn't it Russia look into all those
plays always suggest I'm not sure I'm
not sure this rule is this was a
one-year rule so I'm not sure it's going
to get 24 votes again but again I want
to sit down and look at the play and
listen to our River on and we easily
have a couple of other
the two inches here their perspective on
it and I just think it's I'm
uncomfortable with where where it sits
right now but but there's gonna be a lot
of discussion over the next few weeks
even a few months before the league
meeting in March okay and this is the
last one for you John Mara as you know
John Madden said when he went into the
Hall of Fame that he believes the busts
talk to each other or the lights go down
when George Young bust goes in the room
what's the conversation you think's
gonna have had between your dad and him
the one thing that George is to say all
the time and we still laugh about it we
still said here you would say John
whenever they say it's not about the
money money over it over to us for so
many years right again it's a line what
we still use here and I can still see it
I can see them saying that and in the
bus room again for sure and I'm sure a
lot of people would agree I'm sure
there'll be a chorus in that room hey
congrats on getting that news about
George I know it means a lot to me
personally and you got it thanks to the
call appreciate it always enjoy a chat
thank you that's John Merrow of the New
York Football Giants right here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app